termino la visita a china de la alta
comisionada de la onu para los derechos
humanos michelle bachelet en sus seis
días de viaje fue a dos de las ciudades
más importantes de xinjiang la provincia
donde denuncian que el gobierno chino ha
detenido forzosamente a miembros de la
minoría musulmana uigur y los ha
obligado presuntamente a trabajar
beijing niega las acusaciones y dice que
intenta frenar el separatismo bachelet
respondió pidiendo que las políticas
antiterroristas no violen los derechos
humanos para analizar el tema nos
acompaña a carlos veríssimo experto en
temas de china y eeuu y presidente del
foro uruguay democrático
bienvenido a france 24
michelle bachelet aclaró que su visita
de alto perfil no implica
investigaciones porque importa entonces
este viaje a china
varía claro el día la visita realmente
es algo histórico hace 17 años que no
teníamos la visita de un alto
comisionado de naciones unidas al china
ya ese hecho es un hecho que es muy
relevante
la prensa manejó incorrectamente unos
días antes de que ella podría haber
hecho una investigación pero es
imposible hacer una investigación una
sola persona en tan poco tiempo sobre un
país que no tiene indicadores no tiene
un análisis y tampoco tiene grupos que
de alguna forma puedan contrastar los
derechos humanos desde la población en
definitiva vale su visita es una visita
importante muy importante a nivel
internacional para los derechos humanos
pero que de alguna forma significa solo
eso un avance
naturalmente si hoy china está con ganas
de
de alguna forma reiterar la voluntad que
tiene de apertura debería abrirse a
distintos grupos de análisis de derechos
humanos para contrastar la información
china con la realidad 89 millones de
mujeres no puedan ser censados en una
visita de una sola persona en seis días
y china afirmó que bachelet debería
permanecer en una burbuja a causa de la
pandemia que tanta libertad tuvo la alta
comisionada en su viaje a china
es justamente eso maría clara en la
burbuja fue algo que también la impulso
para los que fueron las olimpíadas no sé
si lo recordamos
es una muy buena excusa primero para no
mostrarle toda la realidad mostrar un
centro de reeducación como dicen ellos
éste ya no tenía actividad porque
supuestamente los los que estaban
talentos intentando reeducarse
voluntariamente habían sido egresados
ella no pudo hacer una visita realmente
profunda realmente ha tenido algunos
contactos con algunos líderes locales
con algunos gobernantes locales pero no
con la realidad total de la etnia uigur
en chiste y sin esta profundidad como
usted lo dice entonces explíquenos cómo
impacta para los uigures la visita de
michelle bachelet
del punto de vista práctico para la
etnia uigur no le va a impactar en nada
realmente china lo que debe estar
haciendo en este momento es usando la
visita de michelle bachelet como forma
de decir bueno señores vino un alto
comisionado de derechos humanos saca el
país y en definitiva no constató ningún
hecho de alta gravedad es parte de la
política de desinformación que tiene hoy
china
indudablemente mostrar de alguna forma
de contrastar la realidad y mostrar la
verdad significa análisis en este caso
no lo hubo sí pero no no desvirtúa y no
le merece la visita de bachelet en todo
caso